hey what is up guys I'm Kim PhD here and
welcome to an ask me video so this is
the fourth one I've done a couple of
these before and I just asked on
Facebook and Twitter just to ask
questions of what you guys want to know
about and a lot of you guys asked them
so I'm going to be answering some of the
more popular ones and some of the more
interesting ones now right off the bat I
know a lot of you guys have noticed that
this is not a normal shirt that I've
worn in videos in the past and I get a
lot of questions often about just what
shirts I wear in videos 90% of the time
it's an ultimate frisbee Jersey so
that's just because I have so many of
those and then the last 10% of the time
is just some whatever cool shirt design
I found somewhere on our BCA or Amazon
or something now adding to that is going
to be mkbhd designed shirts this is just
the first one this is a very basic
looking mkbhd logo a little bit of an
interesting design and you can check out
the first link in the description to get
this exact shirt in black or red I'm
going to be designing random ones based
on like what I think is neat at the time
it's not always going to be an mkbhd
logo but it might be some text or it
might be some collaboration stuff with
other youtubers other tech stuff might
be some awesome phones or whatever
whatever happens it's going to be a
pretty sweet tech looking shirt and
these are actually the same company that
made the Tesla shirt that I've worn
before so pretty quality stuff I like
this design but every single one of
these is going to be a limited edition
run of that design so they won't make
these forever but you can get this
internationally until they stop making
them and that's it for the t-shirt stuff
alright so how has your Ultimate Frisbee
team been doing lately right so I play
for a couple of teams I haven't actually
fully explained this ever on video I
play for a club team called Garden State
that season hasn't started yet that's
like a summer thing I play for a protein
called New York Rumble that season
starts in two weeks and I might as well
put their link in the description below
that's hopefully going to be great and
then I'm currently playing right now for
my college team which is sort of in the
middle of the post season right now and
so far we've won our section two and oh
and we're moving on to regionals for
sort of the Metro East that's gone
pretty well too hardest thing to explain
about technology to someone from 50
years ago 50 years ago is a long time
if you think about it the internet as a
whole wasn't really a thing 50 years ago
and just the entire concept of an
interconnected virtual world would
probably be the hardest to explain
Allison can you explain what internet is
well the quantity of videos you do
increase after graduation if so by how
much actually I want the quality of the
videos to increase after graduation
right now I'm making videos and the
hardest part about it for me right now
is that it's split up making videos in
between like classes so I might shoot a
video one day and then shoot the rest of
it the next day after class and then
edited that night after another class
and it's so broken up and discontinuous
that it's kind of hard to maintain focus
or like a goal or an image for what I
want it to be so I feel like having a
bunch of continuous time in a row to
work on things will help make the videos
better and I guess inevitably there will
be more stuff to work on but not having
to go to class every day will certainly
free up a lot of time what manufacturer
does not currently make smartphones that
you feel would make an interesting one
that's a really interesting question I
actually immediately in my head I went
to car companies like Porsche and
Lamborghini but they actually already
make a Lamborghini phone so that's not
really an option and then I went to
Tesla Tesla doesn't already make phones
but they do make like a giant
touchscreen interface and their software
engineers and they can build that stuff
it's not the most beautiful or smooth
interface in the world but I wouldn't
put it past a company run by Elon Musk
to build something pretty impressive
sharp announced a fork a five point five
inch phone screen with an 806 pixels per
inch do you think it's necessary well no
it's not necessary
I'd just like when we had 720p phones
1080p phones are not necessary 2k phones
are not necessary but they're beautiful
and they're pushing the limits of
technology and I can't really say no to
that I love it now as far as content
goes you'll be able to use your phone's
interface and probably watch some videos
and look at photos in 4k but past that
point it's going to be sort of pushing
the boundaries for a limited return
right now you can't even watch youtube
videos in 2k on every 2k phone but I do
like the idea of being able to see
basically no pixels from a basically
zero viewing distance this also has
great applications for VR if you put a
phone with a display like that and a VR
headset it's going to look a lot better
than even a 2k display does now so
necessary No
beautiful and potentially extremely
awesome yeah your thoughts on the m9
plus alright so I published my HTC One
m9 review a couple of days ago and like
1 day later HTC announced that in China
only they're going to have a slightly
larger version of the m9 kind of like
the m8 Maxx from last year and it's
going to have a home button with a
fingerprint reader it's going to have a
bigger better battery it's going to have
updated internals and a 2k display and
all these other interesting things that
we would have liked to have seen in the
m9 and everyone got all mad and stuff
about it but I don't really think that's
that big of a deal it's also not that
unusual for other companies to pull off
in these markets where bigger phones are
much more popular do I wish it was
coming to the United States so I could
use it absolutely I might even try to
import one and might review it and see
if it's worth checking out but for now
I'm not even that mad just kind of
interesting thing we'd be buying the 8k
dragon from red short answer yes
my order actually is already in now it
doesn't start off as a neikei camera
it's a new body for the version of the
camera I'm shooting with now which is
the red epic dragon and a lot of you
guys know I've been shooting on this
camera for a while now it's the carbon
fiber version and then you get an 8k
sensor upgrade at the end of 2015 or
sometime in 2016 so my name is on the
list to be among the first to get that
and it's not just the 8k sensor that's
awesome it's also bigger than full-frame
and it's also the huge dynamic range and
the colorscience and the raw and the
frame rates and the smaller lighter
thinner body that makes this camera so
much more impressive but yeah that's
what I plan on upgrading to so yeah
that's about it I do also want to give
some device updates because some things
change and since the last time I showed
a lot of these devices they're a little
bit different first of all the HTC One
m9 got a big update for the camera that
everyone's been talking about and wanted
me to reira view the phone because I
spent a lot of time talking about how
low quality this camera is I reviewed
the International Version my silver m9
which you saw with no branding on it had
that software before all these US phones
are getting a software upgrade so my
review unit and all the photos I took on
it already had the new camera software
so yes it did get better from how dull
it looked before but what you saw was
what everyone's getting now the Nexus 6
which I keep putting my sim card back in
for some reason
so much got the android 5.1 update and
it feels like a new phone it's a
significantly faster smoother and more
fluid experience and I like this a lot
more now that it has this update and the
battery life is in better - so good for
that and the Samsung Galaxy s6 and s6
edge which is this is the edge my
reviews on that are coming soon so like
I said I have a lot of class I've been
trying to get through the last couple of
weeks of class which is great but I
haven't had time to put together my
review of it now I am actually now in
the shooting stage so I'm making the
video reviews of these guys as we speak
like as you watch this I'm probably
shooting so yeah stay tuned for those
are a little bit later than I thought
they would come but they're coming soon
also this is a deep brand skin it's
carbon fiber and it looks a lot better
than the blue on the back of the regular
s6 sorry Samsung there you go guys
thanks for watching asked me v4 looking
forward to reading and answering your
comments below if you guys get this
shirt or the black version tweet me a
picture of it and I'll retweet my
favorites and that's probably about it
so thanks for watching and I'll talk to
you guys in the next one peace